hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to ink now this game was
just released today on Steam and it
looks really cool it kinda had a super
meatboy vibe dude it's a puzzle
platformer but really colorful and
interesting and it was on top of the
popular chart use this to move cool
use this to jump cool
use this to splatter the entire world
with your goopy ink oh cool
that's so cool it was really cool when I
was watching it it was it seemed really
interesting because one it's got the
really cool concept that it's a puzzle
platformer where you can't really see
where you're going you have to kind of
explore oh wow you have to kind of
explore the environment around you by
splattering the place with your ink
that's such a cool concept I mean the
puzzle platformers are kind of
tried-and-true these days with everyone
pretty much knowing the basic recipes to
it so seeing something new and fresh on
that subject is kind of really cool
because I mean look at that I just well
I died there but when you die you like
repaint everything you still keep the
spaces that you painted okay I'm gonna
nerd out a bit because whenever I see
like a cool game like this it always
like eglee and let me turn on my mic a
little bit because a little bit quiet
but whenever I like see a cool game like
this it's it's really interesting to me
because I love I mean I've been gaming a
long time so I was I always love gaming
innovation whenever see something like
this is always like oh so colorful look
cool but then a part of me is like okay
but then I actually have to try because
I'm willing to bet that because it's a
puzzle platformer it's going to be very
very difficult but I mean I did compare
it to are these oh they're bad for me
but they kind of helped me oh I can jump
on them oh that's cool but they were
also kind of helping me well that didn't
help me at all they're also kind of
helping me because they're splattering
everything with their goop oh I get it
the door won't open until I kill both of
these well you got to die so too bad for
you guys huh yeah there we go
yeah so anyway like I was saying it's
just really interesting to see that some
of these things can you know come out of
a game genre that's been around since
the dawn of gaming puzzle platformers
have been here for
so seeing anything innovative coming out
of it I mean even when super meatboy
came out it was kind of innovative in
that it was obscenely difficult but none
too terrible about anything I actually
like super meatboy a lot and I played it
a long time ago before people started
asking me to play it I played it on a
live stream and I got pretty far in the
game when the game first came out on
Newgrounds I loved it it was flippin
fantastic I played the game to
completion on Newgrounds Oh God dang it
come on you yeah it's getting to the
point where it's harder to talk and play
at the same time come on yeah hippity
hippity oh god it's so finicky on the
[ __ ] direction serial huh oh ok there
we go
getting it getting it getting it getting
it and see I'm a big purveyor of indie
games I believe very strongly in what
indie games represent and what indie
games allow for the gaming community
again I love seeing cool stuff it's not
just cuz I have a DD which I ADHD which
I do and I like seeing pretty colors
well I died alright then but I also
liked seeing innovation so anyway that's
enough of that when we try to actually
concentrate and get through this game
because it's going to be a little bit
more difficult splatter
smaller let me just spray my juices
wherever welp I'm dead now
yep come on where are you happy Hoeppner
hey Bret there we are
ha got you Wow where am I going it's so
weird just walking into the void it's
like a say a big ass
trust fall here come on you hoo total
there we go
there we are oh man it's getting more
complicated oh I couldn't have been that
easy there we go
derided Oh dead ok the real point and
what ok so I imagine I thought this was
gonna be harder than this but maybe I'm
ok never mind I'm talking a big game but
I should just shut my big gob before the
ink escapes out of it
oh no no Oh death I thought death was
coming for me
death sweet speedy death ah there we go
I don't know if this would qualify as
needing a seizure warning though because
it does have a lot of colors but I don't
know it's flashing so I'll put a
flashing warn it on and I'll Pete a
seizure warning at the beginning this
video anyway which obviously you saw
because it was already there but it's
just a little interesting because I
don't know Ronna thinks that I'm trying
to concentrate here
trying to come up with cool commentary
and me and Jack we were just playing
together with whole bunch of games so
expect some games from me and him very
soon but he was talking to me and he was
explaining to me how lazy my commentary
had gotten these days cuz we were trying
to play the forest again and for some
reason my internet is still borked here
over at the grump office so I have
trouble playing multiplayer games with
people god dang it son of a oh [ __ ] you
you son of a [ __ ] and I'm trying to god
it's wholehearted talking boy no god
dammit you son of a [ __ ] get back here
he's just a little bit slidy
a little bit too slighty more than I'd
like there we go yeah okay now
concentrating talking at the same time
so so for some reason like I have
trouble playing multiplayer games which
is why it's like I've wanted to play GTA
5 for a long time but it's really hard
to play with people because oh come on
what a sack of crap what a load of ass
bags what a piece of poop yeah here you
some oh [ __ ] you you piece it all right
way
sorry anyway um what wasn't saying
totally lost here I'm trying to get this
done without being stupid
and it's not the game that's being
stupid it's just me that's being stupid
what was I even talking about I have no
idea
God thing it was probably really
important really in god ding oh there we
go okay anyway what was I talking about
uh me and Jack playing without a Zune
Oh GTA v I've wanted to play GTA v again
for a long time but because my recording
setup has not been like in my own house
which people probably deduced over time
ah it's not been in my own house I've
been working at the grump office which
has been awesome not complaining but
[ __ ] not complaining about that in any
way but they have some security measures
on their internet that makes it
difficult to be able to play with the
people that I want to play so I don't
know it's like it's like I it's been
happening for so long and because I've
been moving a bunch I haven't been able
to get my own home base set up so I'm
hoping that's gonna change
Rell its god I have to come straight
here
combo combo combo wombo combo flap you I
almost died there father died there I
would have been very upset I'm getting
to the point where I'm a little bit
antsy here here Oh Oh what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] son of an ass blasting [ __ ] Lord
crow come on there we go
Oh cakes God did not know how that
happened
but I'm okay I'm a okay this is getting
difficult this is good at getting really
difficult I don't even know how long I'm
gonna be playing this game cuz I don't
think I'm gonna be playing it to
completion I'm just gonna give it a
first look because it was something oh
yes oh yeah yeah oh yeah on you oh yes
soggy it's getting really really
difficult guys don't question it the
controls are still a little
wibbly-wobbly so it's just a little bit
difficult for me to be able to do it
they're making the platform's even
smaller oh what a load of crap okay I
gotta admit uh other commentary that
actually pertains to the game that I'm
playing now I'm not talking about other
games oh what the
brick don't just try it just try it
come at me scrub Lord I've ripped walk
weird figure doing
haha damn it
ah got ya let me scrub Lord I'm wrapped
I'm wrapped uh-huh this is the rule of
threes you're bossing these rule threes
breath you won't get some gear Oh more
okay alright then I was about to talk
about the game but this got in the way
yes unleash that that is definitely
seizure warning holy crap this game
needs a lot of warnings but anyway how's
this oh this we're introducing this are
we well
alright then but either way the music
the environment like the simplicity of
it is really cool but also like the
elegance of how it all is inner mix of
blazed and interstitial eyes in if you
big words you know it looks cool it's
very pretty
I'm happy with it the music works well
with it and it all is very elegantly put
together you'll never watch hey what a
load of baloney this is just lovely
scream is the loveliest [ __ ]
oh come on so we got a little bit of
this going on here yeah okay who's it
work alright damn it
oh come on son of a [ __ ] welp here we
go
you're ready for a whole lot of failure
fudge god I'm not gonna be able to do
this good all that music is so cool oh
it's all so cool it's really cool I got
him it's so cool that is spikes that is
spiky death hip Oh what is that whoa
what is that what did I get
we got like a heart
it'll oh [ __ ] we've gotten look I can't
waste my double jump I gotta get it
before that double jump it looks like I
die when it goes down there come on this
is super meat boy all over goddamnit
oh boy I just get it right the first
time won't need to go back and do it
again that's my philosophy
yeah come on come on peace up poop just
gotta do it right the first time then I
won't have to go back and do it again
he's got Oh son of a [ __ ] Spisak inky
bastard this Dom I didn't use my double
jump I used a wall jump son all [ __ ] you
oh I was fine I was fine I panicked I
was fine
everything was fine I was just being a
ball really oh is that how we're gonna
do this
oh I thought we were gonna play fairly I
thought we were gonna allow me to enjoy
my life
[ __ ] you Jesus
it's a juxtaposition of like the calm
nature of the game and what's going on
in front of me okay what's it what's it
what's the trick here what's the trick
what's the trick now what's it Dow
that's the trick gun gun blender it's
good trackage good trick dad it's good
took my don't over here point it's good
tricky gun oh the hearts up there hey I
got that I did that ahh pass what are
the piss what a bunch of piss goddammit
okay
okay so I don't get back up there how in
the hell do I get back up there you
cannot be serious with this baloney
okay I might try from the other side
seems like it might be a little bit
easier on me okay oh oh oh oh I'm so
good oh I'm so good at everything
oh and the best oh look at me look at me
why you looking at me why I should look
at right okay there we go yeah oh I
shouldn't be going down yet Oh cities
did eat it eat it ease Gabriel it's
gonna be the last level I do once I get
this expertly it's gonna be done Oh Oh
pee in my pants okay let's look at this
will be a okay
hey okay hey okay ray okay oh yes
actually no I'm gonna get to the next
boss battle that's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna get to the next possible who we're
moving now oh we're a bunch of movie
movers ah you can't get me I'm too smart
for you and also you're too dead
also you are dead maybe there we go okay
introducing the concept of moving it's
not okay for me because I can't even
introduce the concept of staying still
and not dying
Oh Toby Toby Toby a poopy poopy Oh what
we okay booby booby booby booby booby
booby yes okay we're good we're good
we still moving okay no we're not
nevermind oh we are moving oh well [ __ ]
come on get there we go Creek bunch of
all OH
it's like sticky when it shouldn't be
sticky such a sticky SAP of saca crap
get out of my face there we go
yeah whoa
little mutts they're a little much a
little much what do we got nothing
okay cool secret okay what do we got
here whole bunch of death what's a death
and destruction bunch of death and
destruction who do we got who we got I'm
so I'm dead it's really cool that after
a while you keep playing and it's like a
tie-dye project going on here ah piss
okay
and it's like a sense of exploration too
because it kind of brings that element
in because you're you're playing the
game but you're also exploring what the
level actually is while you're playing
it which is a cool thing very cool
indeed
hot dead aah
you tricked me Oh is there something
over here no no that just leads back
down all right try this again I got it
now and then as you're playing like it
becomes technically easier because you
see more of what's around you I mean I
guess if you want to consider that being
a little easier but it's also cool just
because hey it's like this whole level
is here and you make the level what you
want to make it because it's your colors
that you're spraying all over it so
technically when two people are playing
it may not be all that similar just
because it's kind of cool whoa way well
don't crush me don't crush me bro okay
I'm gonna get you
come on get you yeah I got you where's
this next boss where's this boss [ __ ]
where's the damn boss where's is pooping
bossy poop oh whoa what I was on tabatha
I would go on top of it ah I got
squished I got so squished let me out
this [ __ ]
why did I jump that way that's a mystery
I'll never solve
hey holes
yeah so why also another Oh God oh man
oh wow okay yes another good question is
why am i killing these innocent little
colored what is whoa what is this
what is this who's this was this baloney
where's my next boss battle god damn it
okay you know actually I'm done for now
because running too long but either way
okay so I'm done here uh screw it I'll
solve this one poink poink oh you can't
kill me with your Dorito guns anyway
that's all play for now thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think of this game in the
comments below I would love to hear your
input on it it's really pretty the
soundtrack is really cool and it offers
a unique challenge and a twist on puzzle
platforming so this games on Steam I'm
not being paid to play it in any way so
you can check it out for yourself I
think it was five dollars so thank you
again everybody for watching check out
the other cool games that I played in
the comments below or the description
below in the annotations over there I'm
screwing this up but who cares thanks
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next video
because he wanted to nestle in my bosom
I wasn't ready for that love take me to
dinner first
you